you and Anthony directed a biggest movie
of all time
which made cherry and I know that
whatever you choose to do next
you'll get your run a production company
so you could make literally anything you
want so what what is it that you guys
are looking at now in terms of films
that you want to make because you have
that ability to do whatever you know on
a personal level it's just about the
stories that we want to tell on how we
connect to those stories we have
projects that we've been working on for
years that that we want to bring to the
screen we have secret projects big you
know big new universe projects that
we're working on that we want to bring
to the screen so you know we've we've
got you know three projects ready to go
that we will probably direct in
succession over the next two two and a
half years so what we're going to be
very active in the next two two and a
half years and you know we'll announce
those when the time is right but you
know they run the gamut and you know we
of course love action so you know I'm
sure one of those could be an action
film and and there's some there's some
big universe stories in there as well a
lot of people are talking about
directing for six or eight episodes on
Ana Netflix or on an Amazon um have you
and Anthony talked about doing something
that's you know eight episodes or ten
episodes on a Netflix you know now that
you have that partnership
I think the best storytelling that's
happening right now is in is in you know
longer form storytelling you could call
it TV I don't know that you can even
call it TV anymore frankly because it's
it's now it's as equally cinematic and
and as compelling a narrative level you
just get to do a much deeper dive with
the characters spend more time with them
you can create more surprises you can
break the format like I said to our
narrative is very specific and when you
get to ten hours you can do you can make
a lot of different choices that you
can't make in two hours you can also get
the audience more emotionally invested
in your characters because you know just
on a practical level they're spending
more time with them
so yes we love all mediums we've worked
in them our entire careers we have no
bias about that we never have you know
we're you know we don't we don't try to
take a point of view that one is better
than the other and they just all you
know the different mediums work for
different stories you know depending on
what story you want to tell so a hundred
percent we would and are interested in
committing to like a long-form project
at some point it's not what the it's
without one of the next three things I'm
talking about but we would definitely
commit to it